foreign
good morning um if everyone please join
me in Rising for the Pledge of
Allegiance
for which stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you
this time I'm an opening executive
session on House Bill 113
and I recognize representative Rhodes to
make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
retain uh House Bill 113
is there a second second
Ed that
sounds like proof
on the roads
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chairman
um
after talking with a lot of the
stakeholders in this particular Bill and
some members of the general public
there's some information that has come
forward that we think we could actually
address in this bill and additionally
some of it may be able to be made in the
rules and not actually have to be in
legislation
would you like to speak to your second
representative Pro
okay
would anyone discussion representative
Stone
I'm all set Mr chairman anyone else
no I'm good okay
um
initially I like this bill and I still
kind of like it but um it's been brought
to our attention from the law
enforcement community that they would
like to have a chance to look at it a
little bit further there was some
difficulty in getting feedback from all
the stakeholders so rather than voice
this upon them I'd like to give them a
better chance to look at it and give us
more input so by retaining the bill it
doesn't kill it we'll still act on it by
October and we'll come up with something
without further discussion I will ask
the clerk to call the roll
and the promotion is to retain
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Lynn
representative Prue yes
representative janvin yes
representative Manion yes
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes
representative tenzai yes representative
gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler no
chairman Roy
CE yes motion passes 19-1 the bills were
changed
so I'm going to close the executive
session Hospital three
and I open the executive session on
House Bill 156 just for the edification
of the comedian knows in the gallery
here I'm skipping over one three five
because there's an amendment coming it's
not here yet and we'll we'll get into
that and discuss it when it arrives so
156 and I recognize I'm representative
to make a motion
um Mr chairman I actually was just on
the phone with uh oh
yeah all lasts about five minutes ago
they're redrafting my amendments so I
should be getting an email very shortly
we seem to have an OLS Log Jam this
morning
um
in that case I'm going to recess
the executive session in hospital 156.
open the executive session on House Bill
and recognize representative Pratt for a
motion
a motion on 328 is itl
is there a second
second
representative mannion representative
Pratt would you like to speak to your
motion
this bill is uh in regards to different
kind of drugs that we've been looking at
all along here this is a lazaric
diethylate made mescaline which is LSD
and I'm sure I butchered those and
there's another one pcps here or any
analog similarities to these drugs
these drugs uh don't really have a
beneficial outcome to the people that
take them and I just want to ATL the
Bill thank you
represent man you like to speak to a
second
uh no I believe he coveted it thank you
for the discussion
representative Muse
thank you I plan to support the itl but
one of the things that I I do want to
point out is that
um these particular substances have
increasingly been shown to help people
um who have mental health issues
especially folks who have PTSD in other
states uh there are legalization efforts
that have either succeeded uh or that
are in progress and the people asking
for this aren't drug users on the street
they're people like veterans and police
officers
um unfortunately when bills like this
come to our committee
um we we have to take a very narrow
focus on on legalization and how things
fit into the controlled Drug Act and and
what the potential is for harm across
the board
um the sad thing is that substances like
this
increasingly are being recognized for
the potential for good that they have uh
and under the supervision of a of a of a
medical doctor or or some type of
clinical setting I believe they could be
tremendously helpful to people
um but straight legalization at this
point is something that I I I I don't
think we should consider because of the
potential impact on younger people
um and people who may not understand
what they're taking
um
so with that said I I do plan to support
the itl but for very different reasons
than my colleagues thank you
thank you I would add that I actually it
would be the same reasons as I I think
that there are potential benefits in
some of these but they need to be
medically vetted and and
ex not experimented but at least trials
in uh in a more controlled setting
before they're just we discuss just
cutting it Loose to the public at large
representative Bolden
today I learned that five minutes in
Amanda's Standard time is 20 minutes
um
I I'd like people within New Hampshire
um working in science to be able to
study the benefits of this and I think
that's why I'll be supporting the bill
represent wheeler I think that
you know we're here to discuss the
criminalization of these substances and
I think that
through the conversations we've had over
the years if some of us have been on the
committee for years uh about the
legalization of these substances has
proved that the criminalization does
nothing but allow the law enforcement
Community to go and and pick people up
for for holding substances that have no
real harm to the society at large and
frankly I I think that um you know I
won't use the term War on Drugs because
I don't think that necessarily like you
said Mr chairman means much anymore but
I will say that the criminalization of
these substances has played a serious
role in breaking up uh communities
across our country and I think that if
we want to move forward having them as
representative Bolden said study the
substance be able to experiment with it
as you said Mr chairman I think we have
to legalize it and I think we have to I
think starting from that standpoint is
much better than uh continuing to
stigmatize it when frankly this is a
substance that that again has no real
harm and and does by the studies have
serious benefits
thank you
representative Noel
don't worry I'll be quick
um thank you Mr chairman I just wanted
to say agree on all the points actually
made
um and I I'm I'm very much supportive of
uh legalization and uh regulation but
there are steps that need to be taken to
get to that because regardless of how we
got to this point we are at this point
we are where we are and uh especially
you know with subsistence being mixed in
with other things and stuff like that I
think it's very important that we have
the Protections in place before we uh
just outright legalize something so I'll
be supporting the idea thank you and I I
would just um I would add that I would I
would like to see this come back
um in some form in the future as a
medical bill versus just a criminal
justice Bill representative wheeler
the substances are being mixed right now
uh there's only so much that we can do
as a state to put in protections for
people uh with substances like these
people will make them
regardless of their if they're illegal
or not
um they will attempt to concoct this
substance using High School uh
science class level knowledge uh whether
we legalize it or not but if it's legal
then scientists who right now uh
professors who right now have an
interest in studying it in New Hampshire
schools will be able to pursue their
interests without fear of the stigma
without fear of criminalization without
fear of arrest and actually be able to
move forward to get us to the position
that representative Newell is looking
for legalization of these substances
under this legislation gets us to the
position that representative Newell is
looking for so I will be voting for
against the itl motion
thank you and I look forward to hearing
that compelling speech again on the
floor
with that I'll ask the clerk to call the
rule
Ocean on the floor is an experience
legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative Lynn yes
representative Prue yes representative
janvin
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
Catherine yeah
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
no
representative Bradley
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes no representative Newell
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy
terrible chess motion passes 17-3
motion of inexpediate to legislate
passes 17-3 who would like to write The
Minority Report
so
I I will Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman if I may I just um what I was
going to say was I
I have been approached and it's been
specifically requested that we actually
write down who is going to do the
Minority Report
um so that in the event that our
committee assistant has to chase
somebody down she actually knows who
she's chasing down and
um
about the manner of having them done or
they're unfortunate not going to be able
to be in the calendar for the floor
thank you
okay
um representative Pratt will you be
writing the majority report yes thank
you and I closed the executive session
on House Bill 328 open the executive
session on House Bill 344
and I recognize representative Reed to
make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I moved to retain
this bill
is there a second
seconded by representative gaps right
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman um I think we should retain
this bill because there's a bill in
Commerce already covering this and we
need to make sure where that Bill's at
because they may have
um stripped this part out they may not
have so until we get a better handle on
what's coming out of con Commerce I
think we should retain this bill
thank you representative gathwrite would
you like to speak to you a second well
said thank you for the discussion
representative Newell I see you
I just like to clarify that in um what
is it six three eight the one that's in
Commerce
um it does not include the legalization
of a home cultivation and so I I really
wish we could vote on this today because
if we don't then we're just this is not
um it's it's a home cultivation is not
going to be legalized if we don't you
should be clear retaining it we will it
doesn't mean that it's done we will we
have to act on it by October so okay
um representative uh Murray
thank you Mr chair I was going to say
the same as representative Newell that
the home cultivation part of of 639 I
believe it was was taken out and we
passed it on the floor without
um that piece yesterday so I would
support otping this bill today
thank you I didn't realize we had so
many green thumbs on the committee
um
further discussion you don't know that
okay seeing none I'll ask her to call
the role of motion on the floors
retained
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt no
representative Lynn yeah
representative pru
representative Jan Wren yes
representative Manion
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenzai yes representative gathrate yeah
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
no
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes no representative Newell
no
representative Brennan
yes representative wheeler
chairman
gerbilt yes voters fifteen five
the bill is retained by voter fifteen to
five here by close executive session on
House Bill 344.
and open the executive session on House
Bill 376.
and recognize representative Jan burn to
make a motion
Mr chairman I move art to pass
second by representative gathright
representative Cameron would you like to
speak to your motion
absolutely yeah the
stakeholders that came before this
committee testified that there is no
standard if you go to police the police
have standards if you go to the fire
academy the fire academy has standards
there has not been a telecommunications
Academy that once was held I believe
they said by the police academy in many
many many years so uh I think that if we
standardize the the requirements and
training for our telecommunications
Specialists I'm not going to call them
dis factors that it would make us all
safer
thank you representative gathright would
you like to speak to you a second
as well
thank you for the discussion
I think this is a beneficial piece of
legislation that's going to help um
the emergency Community as well as the
community at large so I also endorse
those bills ought to pass I would ask
the clerk to call the roll please
chair Rhodes yes representative Pratt
yes representative Lynn yes
representative Prue yes representative
janvin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensor yes
representative kathry yeah
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Brennan yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Wright
share about yes motion is unanimous 20-0
motion of ought to pass is unanimous any
objection to consent seeing none of go
on the consent calendar uh hereby close
executive session on House Bill 376.
no excuse me yeah I apologize I know I'm
a guest here but
more education on another matter and
they texted me saying that there and are
ready for me to go over so I'm wondering
if I could be excused how long do you
need to try to make it 10 minutes yeah I
would say about 10 minutes okay um Mr
chairman also the amendment that I
requested has arrived so I got to go up
and make copies so if we can do that
okay let's take a 15-minute recess while
we collect our amendments and the
representatives thank you
that's good because my amendment is
jacked up too yeah mine's probably
jacked up
okay
and sheets because
yeah who complained about that the we
haven't been putting who was going to be
doing The Minority Report because often
what's said is somebody will do it and
then it's I guess it's not
it's just somebody may be doing it but
they're not coming in before the
calendar to begin and then they have the
whole
and this time we're going to
re-open the executive sessions I believe
that we had already opened the
executives no I was about to open the
executive session on which one
41. thank you
yeah he's in the hall I believe
representative tenzar could you would
you mind stepping out and see if
representative Lynn's out there
this time I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill 481 relative
arrest warrants and I recognize
representative janvin for a motion
Mr chairman my motion is itl
is there a second
representative Peru
representative Jammer would you like to
speak your motion yes uh the prime
sponsor testified before us and
explained his bill quite succinctly uh
one of the things that I noticed uh was
the bill is seeking to stop police
officers from
judge shopping I guess is the best uh
the best sling to use
but what it doesn't take into account is
that a Justice of the piece can assign
an arrest warrant
all they need to be is neutral and
detached from the subject
that's to be arrested and that would
allow say Portsmouth Police Department
to go to Northampton police Sergeant
who's a justice of the peace and swear
out a warrant for the arrest
if if this bill were to pass
um
and
the the sergeant in Northampton says I
can't sign it because I'm not neutral
and detached I arrested them last week
now they have to go to another justice
of the peace or Justice of the court and
um they'd have to make out a big long
explanation that we went to this guy
he's a justice of the peace and he he
didn't deny it but he is not neutral and
detached
so I can't issue the warrant it just
it's an it's a very very
unfortunate uh that
the bill came to us because it actually
makes it so much harder for a police
officer to get a warrant when honestly
time could be a very very big factor in
getting that warrant so I I definitely
would like to uh itl the bill for that
for that reason thank you Robertson Peru
did you want to speak to your second
I agree with the other representative
and and uh
you think it
it could cause undue delays in getting a
warrant
um
and some confusion on on it so I don't
think it's the right bill at the right
time thank you thank you I would add
that it's it's it seems to me on its
face rather presumptive that that there
are Judges within the court system that
that are willing to um to do things they
shouldn't so that police officers might
be shopping for a certain judge I think
that's very presumptive and and I don't
I don't think that we should be thinking
that way at all borrowing some evidence
that it has occurred or is occurring
further discussion
seeing Oh representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I was just wondering if any of my
colleagues could offer some
clarification regarding my understanding
of the bill was that it would simply
request that that information be shared
and not necessarily that it would stop
someone from being able to go to another
judge to get um the warrant approved
actually yes so in in this situation
you're right it would require that it be
shared with
every time you went to another Justice
it would have to be shared to that
Justice and the situation I explained
Portsmouth PD wants and the rest weren't
they go to Northampton that Sergeant
says no because I know that person I'm
not neutral and detached so now they go
to Newington and that Justice of the
piece says no I know that person so they
go to and they end up before a district
court judge
um for their warrant because no justice
of the peaceful issue it because they
all know the guy so now it's going to
take that police officer
valuable time to explain to the Justice
why none of these justices of the piece
I issued the warrant so I think it's
just very onerous for the police officer
further discussion
representative Newman
yeah just to follow up
is the significant thing that the judge
in that situation that you described or
all of the people involved knew the
person or is it that they have to bring
that type of information to the person
and if if that is so it's written so
wouldn't they just be taking the same
information I'm trying to figure out
what the delay is
well actually I I think in the the way I
EX
the situation I explained
um it may not be that the Justice of the
Peace So if it goes to the justice and
he says they have to give all that
information
the Assumption or the presumption by
that Justice may be that the others
denied
signing the arrest warrant because there
was not probable cause or there was
exculpatory evidence or whatever and
that police officer again has to explain
himself to that Justice I just think
that it makes more sense
that if if the reason that they're not
issuing the warrants because they're not
neutral and detached from the subject of
their arrest warrant that it really
would delay having to explain to the
next Justice piece why they didn't get
the warrant from the first thank you
um I would add that it kind of in a way
encourages police officers to have to
inject hearsay into a into the warrant
process
when they go to one judge they have to
say the reason they're speaking on
behalf of the other Justice or judge in
in
versus that person telling themselves it
it interjects something into that isn't
there I haven't we didn't hear from
anyone about a case where this happened
we haven't heard um
really anything this is just it seems to
me a solution to sort of a problem
so for that reason I I would definitely
support the itl on this it's a very
already a complicated process and when
you get into court after and you have
defense attorneys looking at
um
reasons to and justifiably that's their
job to get their client off and they can
start saying wait a minute this officer
said this is that exactly what the judge
told him you're going to have judges
subpoenaed into court as material
witnesses as to why they didn't do it or
didn't sign it and it's going to
complicate the process enormously with
that I'd ask the clerk to call the roll
foreign
yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Lynn yes
representative Prue yes representative
janvin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative goth right yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes no
representative Newell yes representative
Brennan yes representative wheeler yay
chairman
gerbils yes motion passes 19-1 motion of
inexperienced to legislate passes
um do you object to consent
no objection to consent it will go on
the consent calendar
I close the executive session on
will you be doing a Minority Report or
just you know have to
with that I close the executive session
Hospital
481 open the executive session on House
Bill 503
and recognize
representative proof for a motion
I move itl
your second
second representative Rhodes
representative pru would you like to
speak to your motion
I see this bill as a
way around
oh this legislature funds agencies and
it's kind of like a backdoor funding
process
for the crime lab as much as I
understand that they're probably
underfunded and need more money
um
there's a budget process and this kind
of Skips that so I'm gonna ital that
would you like to speak to your second
representative thank you Mr chair uh
pretty much exactly what representative
proof said I would just add that the the
department themselves have not seemed to
you know come to come to anybody asking
for more funding I think that would be
the first step
agreed further discussion
seeing Nana wants the clerk to call the
roll
motion on the floor is an expedient to
legislate
Vice chair Rhodes
representative Pratt yes representative
Lynn
representative Prue yes representative
Jan Wren yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzai yes
representative Cathay
representative Mia's yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Brennan yes representative wheeler
chairman chairman emotion is unanimous
200.
zero unanimously eye in expedient to
legislate any objection consent seeing
none will be on the consent calendar
here but close the executive session on
House Bill 503 open the executive
session house bill 585.
and representative tensar you have a
motion yes chairman uh move to itl is
there a second
second of our representative Stone would
you like to speak to your motion
representative yes thank you again
chairman uh while I appreciate the
sponsor in filing this bill I just
believe that it is unnecessarily
unnecessary and overly punitive in
nature the first part of RSA 105 20 part
2 Roman numeral 4 is already being
conducted by police standards and
training uh subjecting an officer to a
blood test with a meter complaint of
excessive force uh violates that
officer's due process and also could
violate uh potential collective
bargaining agreements
thank you would you like to speak to
your second representative Stone
Mr chairman I would like to add that
although this does have good intentions
the reality is most departments have a
policy to establish uh drug uh screening
if the department feels is warranted
under their collective bargaining
thank you I would add that singling out
a single substance and saying we're
going to test for this single substance
every time there's an allegation of this
particular ACT
first of all it it to the
it just eliminates all other
possibilities to that one
I think that should an investigation of
an allegation lead to that point then
the local
chief of police or or whoever can
investigate that aspect of it but
mandating that that be part of an
investigation before there's even any
evidence
um doesn't make any sense to me at all
it's an expense and to your point it
definitely would affect the collective
bargaining agreements further discussion
representative Newell
I just wanted to clarify because what I
have written in my notes is that um
was testified to is that hiring
standards can be adjusted too and that's
just my own warning not like quoting but
hiring standards can be adjusted to
include steroids and drug tests so to me
I'm thinking um you know that is a that
is a good part of the bill I think that
that's a good thing to be part of the
standards and training my question is um
that representative tenzar was saying
that it is already part of that and I
just wanted to clarify whether it is or
if that's something that's being
considered to be edited
thank you representative Stone did you
want to reply to that Mr chairman I
would uh initial drug screening is done
during uh pre-employment already so it's
up to the police standings and training
and the Hiring Agency to review what
drugs they want to be screened for at
the time of a conditional offer of
employment usually
um director skip would you like to add
to this before we come to a vote did you
have anything you wanted to add to that
regarding what's going on with the
standards and training with regard to
that
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
ladies and gentlemen uh John skippa
director of police standards and
training for the record uh we the uh
representative stone is correct that we
do uh require that a drug screen be part
of the hiring process it's captured in
RSA 106l
we can do a better job of uh
establishing specific uh
elements to test for in our
administrative rules which uh based on
on the movement of this bill is
something I'm going to bring back to the
council just so that we're we're making
sure that that is actually being looked
at
thank you the committee appreciates your
input and um anything that can be done
be rules instead of Statute I think is
much better because it can be it's much
more flexible to be adjusted thank you
for adding to that anything further
seeing nonetheless the court to call oh
what would I miss oh sorry
representative means I just I just
wanted to add that uh one of the things
that's kind of swaying me is the fact
that we really would be taking away the
due process rights of of an officer uh
uh if we if we simply require them to
you know to get this test after any
excessive force complaint
um and uh and we took action you know
without any kind of a hearing so
basically
um you know if if there's an excessive
force complaint against you and your
test positive you're out
um uh it just seems to be a pretty big
step to take in addition to some of the
other arguments we've heard
thank you that's the point is well taken
um
at this point I'll ask the court to call
the rule the motion of the floors and
excuse to legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Lynn yes
yes representative Prue yes
representative janvin yes representative
Manion yes yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes representative cathry yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler yay chairman
Sheriff yes promotion is unanimous
20-0 in expedient to legislate any uh
objection to consent
seeing none it will go on a consent
calendar and I hereby close the
executive session on House Bill 585 what
was that 35 yeah and I opened the
executive session on House Bill 589
and I recognize representative janvin to
make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move in
expedient to legislate
seconded by representative gathright
representative chamber would you like to
speak to your motion absolutely
um so
this here seeks to make well you notice
I hope we understand the bill
um
as a person who utilizes free software
I'm sorry open source software uh
there are times when a developer May
infringe on copyright and to tie the
hands of our police
and um
at the state and local level is is kind
of
overboard I'll use a couple cases about
copywriting Hampton Beach I represent
Hampton at Hampton Beach we have people
that come in and infringe upon
trademarked
uh sports gear that sell it there and
there are several times where they've
been ordered by a court to seize that
um and
I see this bill as saying in that
instance the police officers can assist
so
I I don't see us getting involved in
this I mean
because it has a criminal penalty
attached to it it came to our committee
and actually might have done a better
job in Commerce but I'm definitely
opposed to the to the premise that our
local law enforcement and especially the
sheriff who deals with civil Lawrence is
a civil matter not a criminal matter I
think that it just needs to die on the
tree it came from
representative gathright would you like
to speak to you second
yeah
I just found it to be sort of confusing
me because it's an open source but I
thought that was the purpose of the
software but
other than that
thank you
um I would just say that I think we have
um enough criminal laws and we should
not be getting into tort law and making
a criminal
um
so any further discussion
legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative Lynn yeah
representative Pooh yes representative
janvin
yes representative manian yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative guthright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the chair votes yes representative
Newell I mean sorry the clerk
representative renewal no
representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy cheerful GS motion passes
19-1 19-1 representative uh objective
consent
I'm seeing nor Jacksonville consent
we're going to consent calendar and
expecting to legislate uh here by closed
the executive
on House Bill
589.
and open the executive session on House
Bill 421 and recognize representative
Rhodes for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I would like to make a motion
of ought to pass offer amendments you
guys all have it on your tables it is
20230450h is there a second
it's yes the emotion is adopted a minute
is there a second
second number representative Reed
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chairman um this was
the bill that came to us about
um incarcerated women and hygiene
products we had a subcommittee on it and
the amendment in front of you is the
result of
um everybody that was on the
subcommittee and also the stakeholders
that were here to offer their expertise
on the situation
um we all went over it when I say with a
fine tooth comb I mean down to how we
actually put the sentences in order and
we addressed all of these situations
that were brought to our attention that
we all found pretty egregious and we
fixed that so I would just ask everybody
to please support it
would like to speak to your second
representative Reed I concur with um
Bryce German Rhodes thank you I would
ask representative Rhodes
um
did the commissioner Hanks endorse this
as it is
commissioner Hanks um had her I would
say associate was the other day and this
was actually actually a lot of it was
written with her here
so the answer that is yes and did you
invite representatives from the County
correctional facilities yeah thank you
Mr chairman yes an email was sent out to
um the counties and I was actually given
that information
from the stakeholders make sure I had
the right addresses so everybody that
was here had had their input
did anyone from the counties come
I do not believe so okay thank you
um
I'll I'll just say that I think that the
testimony we've heard was was
um for lack of a better term horrific
um and I'm glad that we were able to
come together on a piece of legislation
to fix it I'm extremely disappointed
that no one from the counties came
um
but they did have their opportunity so
having said that anyone else
representative wheeler totally agree
with what you said Mr chairman the
testimony that we heard in regards to
this bill was appalling and the fact
that that's going on in our County jails
is appalling and I know I'm on my County
delegation and I will do whatever I can
to investigate that further and hope
anyone else who is on their County
delegation or who knows uh the
representative in their District who is
that they would ask that they do the
same thank you that is uh
that's well taken anyone else
representative Bolden I'm not one to
defend the county prisons or jails but
um I do think in their defense that they
were present for the initial
subcommittee meeting out specifically a
lobbyist representing them was sitting
next to you if I remember correctly
and
I think she was fine with everything too
she was pretty she participated that's
what I was asking I couldn't
did they offer any input as to what's
going on in their facilities
she participated in a conversation
it's been a couple weeks and I'm pretty
tired so I don't know
okay I'll take it that it was uh
impactful testimony
um
see no further discussion I would ask
the court to call the roll the motion on
the floors ought to no the adoption the
amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative Lynn yeah
representative proof yes representative
janvin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone
yes representative tenzai yes
representative gathrate yes
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Brennan yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy
terrible chess motion is the amendment
is adopted representative Rhodes do you
have a motion yes thank you Mr chairman
I move ought to pass as amended for
House Bill 421 second
Nancy seconded by representative Murphy
represent Rhodes would you like to speak
to your emotion
um no thank you Mr chair I think we've
summed it up
representative Murphy
anyone else
seeing none
um the motion on the floors ought to
pass is amended known as clerk call the
roll
Vice chairworlds yes representative
Pratt yes representative Lynn yes
representative pru yes yes
representative Jennifer Yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensor yes representative
Catherine yes representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy terrible GS motionless
unanimous
the motion of ought to pass is amended
uh carries unanimously any objection to
consent seeing none it will go on a
consent calendar and I hereby close the
executive session house bill 421. I will
now open the executive session on
House Bill 135 and I recognize myself to
offer an amendment
I'm offering amendment number zero six
eight or h
second
thank you I'll speak to the amendment
the amendment basically adds a section
to this bill this bill was brought to us
to ban no knock search warrants
we heard testimony from law enforcement
that
it's basically not being done now with
regard to evidentiary purposes the
public the public doesn't want these
they oftentimes result in injuries to
either officers or people it's a it's we
asked the police to carry out and um
enforce the laws that we write
and in so doing we have to ensure that
we give them the tools to do it while at
the same time balancing that with the
rights of the public to be safe
and I think this bill accomplishes that
what this amendment does is basically
almost verbatim
takes the policy of the United States
Department of Justice pursuant to
President Biden's executive order on no
knock warrants and adopts it and applies
it for the state
what it does is it bans no knock
warrants except for in the case of a law
enforcement officer safety or the safety
of someone there
I think that's pretty self-explanatory
it requires them to get permission from
their chief law enforcement officer
it also has an exception
if the officer does not have a no-nock
warrant but upon arriving to execute the
warrant they discover that
evidence exists that would make the no
knock warrant necessary again only for
safety purposes of someone there or the
officers
again I think that's self-explanatory
there is one exception for evidentiary
and that's an extreme exception that
would be for example
and this isn't limited to that but it's
an example if they discover there's
someone's been kidnapped or there's
evidence of human trafficking and if the
officers were to knock and announce
there's a great possibility that the
evidence could be destroyed which could
locate a missing person or a trafficked
person
they can get a no knock for that but we
have put a pretty high bar they have to
get permission from their chief law
enforcement officer and from the
district attorney or the Attorney
General of their designee
so this sends a clear message that we
frown on no knock warrants except we're
in
extremely limited circumstances and with
that
I open it for further discussion
representative wheeler question to the
chair
um so
to clarify if a law enforcement officer
felt that his safety was in danger he
could pursue a no knock warrant
um in in pursuant to the second
exception if an officer has a regular
Source warrant that's not a no knock
warrant they go to execute that warrant
and they discover when they get there
before entering that there's a violent
person who may have a firearm
in order to keep them from having to
leave and go back and get the known walk
they can execute or no knock at that
point they have to immediately report
that they've done so to the chief law
enforcement officer who has to also
report it to the district attorney and
they have to articulate why they felt
that that was very necessary at that
time but that's the only exception they
would not be able to show up and say
well there's more evidence and we're
going to lose the evidence so we're
going to do a no knock without
permission that they can't do only exits
and circumstances when they get there to
do the warrant they see this could be
dangerous if we knock and that guy knows
we're out here
does that explain it it does
representative mannion thank you Mr
chair
um before I start I just want to let
everyone know that I've been in law
enforcement about 30 years I'm retired
however I still work on a part-time
capacity before I speak on this but we
heard testimony I can tell you and it's
been in my experience that these
no knock warrants or any high risk
warrants are done by specialized teams
it's not two offices that are going to
show up and kick a door in it's
specialized teams that are trained there
are supervisors that supervise those
teams and we heard testimony from
Manchester that
contrary to what we see on TV they don't
kick doors in wearing black clothes and
masks and rush in and grab someone they
open the door they breach the door so
they can get a look inside before they
make entry and that's generally how it's
done today in my experience and we've
heard testimony on that that's so they
can take a look in the house before they
make entry and they announce themselves
before they go in they don't just kick
the door and then rush in so
um and that's my experience and that's
what I think we've heard as testimony is
how it's done so what we see on TV is
not necessarily not necessarily how it's
done in New Hampshire
thank you
and I definitely agree that was the
testimony we heard and all this bill
does is really just codify what they're
already doing
representative Newell
um I guess you know what I would say is
that
um I just hope that there is a really a
really high bar for taking that action
and it seems like you've written that
into this amendment
um and so I'm going to vote for it I
just I you know I hope that as it's
implemented it's abided by in that way
that we really Reserve that for extreme
situations like that thank you and I
also wrote Into the bill that
um won a warrant like this is executed
once the return is made that means when
they give it back to the court and say
this is what we did and this is what we
found it becomes immediately public
information so that we can watch and see
in the public has a full view of what's
going on
further discussion representative Muse
I just wanted to say that I am I'm going
to support the bill
um and one of the reasons for that is I
don't think uh we should try to toss out
uh the good and quest of the perfect
um I'd be the first to say that I have
some concerns about some of the
exceptions I have concerns that the
language may be a little bit tough for
individual officers to interpret
um but I think we owe police standards
in training and the local agencies the
benefit of a doubt when it comes to
properly communicating what the guard
rails are around this process
um so with that in mind I I plan to
support it and I hope that that the
statute has its intended effect
thank you and if it doesn't we'll be
here to to fix it
um representative Pratt
I studied the original amendment can you
tell me what the difference is between
zero six eight four and zero six eight
one
yes that's the request of um State
Police
the sentence that said if no one
answered would cause them it had the
inadvertent effect of it would actually
freeze them in place if no one answered
the door they would just be stuck there
they wouldn't be able to execute the
warrant I don't think that was the
intent and also
um I did increase it said next business
day on page two and at the request of uh
Chief bronowski I extended it to 48
hours just because it can be difficult
in the North Country for them to track
down a district attorney to make this
report too or if it's on a weekend it
just gives them another day
representative agreed
excuse me Rhodes thank you Mr chairman I
I just would like to add that
I I'm actually very very happy that the
exception for human trafficking human
trafficking or any missing persons was
made sure to be an exception so that we
can do everything we can do to
help save these people
thank you
representative Murphy I'm sorry oh thank
you Mr chair I just wanted to say I will
definitely be in support of this
amendment so I think it actually
uh it benefits both the public and law
enforcement uh the best interest of both
so I'm definitely in support
thank you representative
um
representative new uh Newman
yeah I just have a quick question about
the uh the only Authority that they have
to see is that the chi the chief of the
department if they make a request when
they have to use one because there's
danger to a a person
um and my I just wanted clarification to
we also heard testimony here that all
right comments here
that uh for the for the no knock Warren
warrant they use a lot of times special
um SWOT operations or whatever they do
to to accomplish that and is that what
you think would happen if if
I just see how often that how happened
how often they do that kind of thing get
the special people to do it
um or other circumstances where we just
plainly obvious that a no knock warrant
should be uh administered by the police
that are there
so it is part of the exception
um one of the exceptions is if they have
a regular search warrant and they arrive
and it becomes obvious that a no knock
would be necessary this authorizes them
to do that
and upon doing that they have to make an
immediate report to the chief law
enforcement officer what they did and
why they did it and also has to be
notified to the district attorney as
well so there are checks and balances in
there with regard to the specialized
teams they still have to go through the
same procedure
maybe I didn't understand your question
and I don't blame you for that
[Laughter]
it was kind of convoluted
but but I I guess they they had in that
circumstance that you just described
they would still have to make a call to
at least their chief of police to then
execute it at instead of thank you very
much actually no I want to correct that
no they they don't they they can make
the call at the scene themselves and
immediately after have to because you're
talking about minutes seconds when you
get ready to do a door and you see
there's someone with a gun you can't
pause and make a call and but
immediately upon doing it they have to
report it thank you
representative Stone
I just like to follow up uh based on my
former occupation I used to carry out uh
no knock warrences in addition to
regular announcement or knock warrants
and there's an operational plan that
gets in place before you even execute
the warrant your chief of your
department I can't think of an agency in
New Hampshire where a chief wouldn't
know that a search warrant wasn't being
executed in his jurisdiction by even an
outside agency such as the DEA or ATF so
there's a lot of things in place the
operational plan obviously calls for
additional resources such as EMS on
standby and there's quite a checklist
that goes down before these warrants are
actually carried out and like I said the
chiefs of police usually are very aware
that this is being conducted prior to
the warrant being executed
yeah and I would think there would be
there'd be something to pay if they
weren't
um representative Newell
um I just wanted to clarify and forgive
me if this has already been stated but
clearly
um if the situation is that when you get
there and you realize that there are
exit in certain circumstances
um that would create an imminent threat
of physical violence to the officer and
or another person they would need to
immediately notify uh his or her chief
law enforcement officer who shall
provide written notice to the district
attorney so it's notified but it's not
necessarily get permission in that
moment get authorization but it is the
officer making the um the officers
discretion and good judgment right
notifying and then um obviously that's
public record
and also um as we know it's not going to
be you know too brand new patrolmen out
there um you're going to have a senior
officer on scene who's in command of one
of these teams so um the the Chiefs will
certainly have a responsible person
there to make this kind of call and the
chief will be notified right away and so
that will the D.A representative wheeler
Mr chairman I'm a little concerned that
this bill doesn't change anything I
really agree with representative Rhodes
about the uh section including human
trafficking and I really want to do
everything that we can to get uh to deal
with that because that's one of our
larger issues that we face today but I'm
a little concerned that this is just up
to the discretion of the officer and
there and thus for they would uh they
would have no real record
the officer could just say that that uh
his safety was at risk and and move
forward with the no knock warrant uh and
I I I just don't see this as actually
addressing what the intent of the bill
was which is to to prohibit no knock
warrants and uh and I think
that there is good reason to do that and
I'm not sure that um
allowing the leeway to uh
still pursue one is is the right way to
move forward but I'd be interested to
hear your response to that yeah
absolutely I think when we look at
things like this we have to look at um
we have to look at the imagine if we
didn't so if you can for a moment
picture yourself on the scene about the
execute a search warrant you're all
ready to go it's a knock and announce
and you through a window or through
whatever intelligence someone on the
inside discover
um there's a gentleman in there a
gentlewoman in there who is armed and is
likely to to fire on you when you open
the door and announce
that that's the only discretion they
have is to say oh you know and they have
to articulate it they can't just you
know like you said well I just I felt
unsafe it's going to be a clearly
articulable reason so if we go with the
what if we didn't they would have to
open the door and say police and they're
going to get gunfire
um I think that the the extremely
limited case of allowing that and making
them have to explain it in depth to not
only their Chief but the district
attorney afterwards it gives the public
a chance to see what they did and why
they did it it's no longer a secret and
I think it's the potential the potential
for harm is greater if we don't allow
that exception that it is if we do and
if to your point it becomes apparent
that that has been abused we could
always
strike that later based on evidence but
right now there's no evidence of that so
I don't want to limit that based on no
evidence only conjecture I think this
does change what's currently going on
insofar as even though we hear it's not
happening now we have a clear procedure
in place when it's authorized and when
it's not and also we have now open
window for the public to see where as
before it was a little more onerous to
get these documents now
they become public right away after
they're done
follow-up Mr chairman absolutely I
really appreciate that um
and
hear your side of I think Mr chairman
based on the fact that you likely have
the votes on this amendment I'm probably
going to vote against it I I I was
someone who I remember very clearly the
no-nog Warren that I went through as a
child and uh I I just think the practice
itself is so flawed that
allowing the leeway to to continue that
practice in any way whatsoever I just
want to go back to the time when it
wasn't even legal and I think that
that's what the original Bill does so
given that you have the votes
um I think on principle I'll probably
vote against your Amendment with respect
um no offense taken and that's why we're
here to discuss and I appreciate your
experience brought to share with the
committee representative
so I know I'm only on the fire side
right I'm a deputy chief and I know if I
have people under me that aren't
following the rules God help them right
because it's almost
more wrath than what the other law would
do for you
um and I'd like to hear how you would
get in the house without getting shot
well I'm not a law enforcement officer
representative and I I don't uh claim to
no law enforcement strategy but
um
frankly I do agree with what was brought
up in public testimony and the questions
I think that there are other ways to
arrest the person it doesn't have to be
when the person's in the house I think
very few human beings are all the time
100 in their house and law enforcement
could through the Myriad of surveillance
technology we have right now find that
person when they're outside of their
house and arrest them then
um and of course if that person has
committed a provable haramis a heinous
crime
um that uh their house could be searched
and seized after that person has been
arrested on the street
thank you um happy to do it I actually I
appreciate the I appreciate the
discussion and I um recognize your
position representative wheeler I think
um I'm happy that you added to the uh to
the discussion
um but having said that I think we've
discussed this quite enough I think that
we all know our positions on it and I
hope that um I hope that the majority of
the committee adopts the amendment and I
think that's where we are right we're
yeah okay I'll ask the court to call the
rolling option of amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt
yes representative Lynn yeah
representative pru absolutely
representative janvin
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzai yes representative guthright
representative Muse yes
representative Bolton
this is the amendment right no
uh representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
no
chairman Roy
CE yes motion passes 18-2 with that the
amendment is adopted at this time I will
recognize myself to make a motion of
ought to pass as amended second Mr chair
second about representative Rhodes
um I I don't see that we need much more
discussion I think we've delved into
this pretty deep I would just um respond
and to Representatives sincere represent
wheeler see our concerns I anticipate he
and hopefully I will be here for uh some
time to come and if we need to readdress
this I'm happy to work with you to do so
having said that I will ask the court to
call the roll
ought to pass as amended
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
yes representative Lynn yes
representative pru yes representative
Jan Wren yes representative mannion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzai yes
representative Catherine
representative Muse yeah
representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes now representative Newell yes
representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
yay
chairman Roy
CE yes motion passes 19-1
representative Murray would you object
to consent I do not thank you there
being no objection this will go on
consent and the bill passes out to pass
with that I will open what's the last
one we have
I'm sorry Mr chairman I was not paying
attention I objected to this being on
consent if it's still possible but you
voted yes
objected to it do you want to reconsider
your vote if I could
but Alec Ali could just also object to
it being on consent as well okay with
the procedure
and that'll just save you from having to
pull it after so yeah okay it will not
go in consent
and representative wheeler will write
the minority reports and see are you
going to speak on it right
okay
um
so moving on what's
better yeah
um
what's left yeah 156. I opened the
executive session on House Bill 156.
and recognize
representative janvin to make a motion
or yeah the motion
Mr chairman I move Amendment
202308 I'm sorry zero six eight two
is there a second second
Ed by representative Muse representative
Jan would you like to speak to your
emotional in the amendment
yes uh the Amendments before you would
actually
um
changes
uh section one of the bill
and what it changes is it makes
misconduct
could be described as intentional
misrepresentation of a material fact and
the police report as described in RSC
641 colon 3. 641 colon 3 is unsworn
falsification statute and it defines
this very well so I think that removing
what was in the original Bill and
replacing it with this still
encapsulates most of what was in the
original bill but it just cleans up the
the language and makes it a little bit
easier to understand
representative Muse would you like to
speak to your second
yes I I think uh I think that the
amendment actually does capture uh the
intent of of my original bill
um the part that that actually is
missing is uh specifically calling out
um a misidentification of a person but
um if you take a look at the statute uh
intentional misidentification of
somebody's ethnicity gender or race uh
would actually be covered under under
the statute so what we're we're in
effect doing is really elevating the uh
the uh intentional misrepresentation of
a material effect in a case to a form of
misconduct and we're we're actually
including that in the definition and
what that will effectively do is uh for
uh for police officers who are charged
with that and who go through the process
um one of the things that uh that that
will do will it will make it a
it'll make it a uh the kind of an
offense
sorry about that it will make it the uh
it will make it the kind of offense
that could lead to a suspension of
certification or certificate or loss of
Certification depending on on the
severity of the issue and on on what's
found so
I I think the this this bill was
actually intended to to address a very
serious issue and I and I don't think it
will affect 99.9 percent of law
enforcement officers uh but for that
point one percent uh who might be
thinking about doing something like this
it sends a pretty strong message
um that we take this seriously in New
Hampshire
thank you thank you representative uh
janvin and Muse for that
um I always take extremely seriously any
bill that would in uh anyway Target
the people that we charge with enforcing
the laws that we make
having said that
I believe that there's not a chief of
police in this state who would not take
disciplinary action against one of his
or her officers for an intentional
misrepresentation of fact in any report
or document so I think this is again
just a case of codifying something that
is already being done and um and and it
sends to your point a good message
further discussion
seeing Nana wants the clerk to call the
role on the adoption of the amendment
foreign
yes representative Pratt
yes on the amendment
representative Lynn yes
representative Prue yes representative
janfrin yes representative minion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzai yes
representative gathrie
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Brennan yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy
CE yes motion is unanimous
amendment is adopted unanimously um
representative Jamber would you like to
make a motion Christmas Gemini move
House Bill 156 ought to pass as amended
second anyone
second about representative Peru
representative jambridge like to speak
to emotion
I think we covered it thank you
representative pru
ditto
further discussion
seeing none I lost the court to call the
roll it's now
ought to pass as amended
best chair roads yes representative
Pratt
representative Lynn yes representative
pru yes representative Jan Wren yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tenzai yes representative Catherine
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Brennan yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy
CE yes motion passes 20-0
motion passes
ought to pass any objection to consent
seeing none it will go on the consent
calendar
and I close the public hearing on House
Bill 156.
what
uh excuse me executive session I'm 156.
um with that I will open the executive
session on
House Bill 593
and I'm going to recognize myself to
make a motion
I had hoped to have a conversation with
the prime sponsor of the spill I have
not seen him this morning
having said that
um this spill is a very complicated bill
um and it certainly deserves more than
the week of time we've had to digest it
there is a lot of a lot of work needs to
be done with the court system with the
police with the sponsor
so I'm going to move to retain this bill
to give it a chance to be worked out so
that we can hopefully get buy-in from
everyone who this would affect rather
than just pass it or kill it that's the
chairman no second emotion thank you I
appreciate that I should have asked for
that first but the retroactive second is
appreciated
um so with that I would open it up to
further discussion
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to make sure that the
committee was aware of two amendments
that were offered to us by the sponsors
of this legislation that I'm happy to
move forward to the rest of the
committee and also the co-sponsor of
this bill is in the room right now if we
do have any further questions
thank you and I think that underscores
my point I I haven't seen the Amendments
I think this is a this is a complicated
Bill and um I think it's going to
require a full committee uh work session
I know there was a subcommittee to look
at it and frankly I don't know that they
were able to make enough Headway that we
can clearly understand the the
implications of what it will do in the
court
um I don't think was quite on board yet
a representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman
um I'd just like to reiterate what you
just said we did have the subcommittee
uh meeting on this and the subcommittee
did unanimously vote to retain it pretty
much for all the reasons that you just
said and it is very hard for me to sit
in the criminal justice committee
and make this kind of a vote when quite
frankly I I feel like I'm out of my
league and I don't think that's fair to
the sponsors or anybody else that it
would involve so you know what would
happen to it after it's retained I don't
know if representative Lynn would be
better in his committee but I definitely
feel like I was I feel like a fish out
of water to be quite Frank
thank you um I think that that applies
to anyone who read the bill it is
complicated and we will work probably
with traditional I don't I don't think
that at this point there's any advantage
to try and move it over to judicial
we'll just work with them at the same
time and see representative Lynn would
you like to speak to that yes and thank
you Mr chair um I uh I I agree I'm going
to vote for the retention because I
think the points you make are are valid
ones
um there's uh not in in no way the fault
of of this committee I think we we had
some we had some bumps in the road as we
were as we were kind of working in a
group to getting this together
um and I'm you know how that happens is
I'll is not really particularly
important but I do think that there are
are things that um
that we need to confront and I'll just
give an example uh Chief profansky who I
know is in the room now raised a what it
seems to me to be a very legitimate
point
he indicated that he read the bill
the the part that um
deals with uh uh what's been referred to
as adoptive forfeitures
that he read the bill to mean that if we
were to pass the bill
that the
if there was a situation of a local law
enforcement agency that without any
federal assistance
made a drug arrest let's say
and then
decided and presumably this would be
because it turned out that they got
there were a lot more drugs there than
they anticipated or some other Factor
at any rate
they made the original initial arrest on
their own and then they decide after
that to refer the matter to the federal
government not just for a forfeiture but
for federal prosecution
he indicated he he read the bill to say
that even in that circumstance where the
whole case including the prosecution and
the seizure were referred to the federal
government the state would not the state
wouldn't be able to do that he in other
words and and I certainly had never
intended
I did I don't think I had read the bill
that way but but the fact that he has a
you know a different view of it means
that we at least need to think about
that maybe we need to put some language
in because I certainly I mean I I can
remember from my days as a prosecutor
that it was not at all uncommon
um for us at the in the U.S attorney's
Office to take a case that the state
referred to us uh where the where DEA or
the FED ATF the feds had no involvement
prior uh to to the case being referred
but then to take it for federal
prosecution and and I certainly would
not want to do anything that would
prohibit that because I think that
happens with some regularity and should
be allowed to continue to happen what
what I think
um
the my intent anyway and I think their
intent of the other people that
sponsored this was to prevent the
situation
of a case that is a holy State case it's
prosecuted in State Court there's no
um uh that there's no involvement of the
feds in the actual criminal prosecution
of the defendant but then the forfeiture
is simply referred to the to the uh the
federal government now I know I I from
again from my discussion with Chief
proflonski it may be that law
enforcement doesn't objects to even that
being prohibited and if that's the case
I have to say I do disagree with them on
that I don't I do think that there's a
genuine reason to prohibit the a case
where there's simply local involvement
um in the in the prosecution to then
then refer that to the feds for the
forfeiture only I I do think that that's
that there's a reason to prohibit that
um but that the very fact that we're
having you know I I'm sort of giving you
this explanation suggests that we that
we need to do some more work on this
bill so that we make sure we
um we're we're all sort of on the same
page and to the extent that retention
will allow us to get there
um I I can certainly support that
thank you and coming from the former
Chief Justice of the state supreme court
I'm thoroughly confused now so that's
good
that that we I think we definitely we
definitely need to retain this bill
um any further discussion representative
I would just like to find out if you
have you is that a retention would allow
this bill to be worked on by the
appropriate people to come together with
the appropriate outcome that is
absolutely my intention I plan on making
sure everyone at the table understands
this and has at least some type of an
agreement on how it should proceed and I
think that was a more concise question
it was actually very good and I I would
say to the extent of you know Judiciary
we're happy to work with you on this I
have no problem and I'm sure
representative uh uh Papa Richie Muller
would all who's here would also be
willing to work with us uh uh on that as
well as representative McGuire
um I that is good to know because we
will definitely be using that resource
representative jambrian
thank you Mr chairman uh as most of you
would recall uh
before I took a break from the house I
actually served on Judiciary Committee
for four years and in those four years a
bill similar to this came to us twice
and my recollection we can have our
researcher look at it but my
recollection was
a bill almost exactly verbatim to this
bill came before Judiciary in 2019
and the the committee
amended it to divert the funds that were
taken by any forfeiture to a different
use and that's why the bill failed
um but I remember that
judiciary had had because it was a civil
matter in that bill not a criminal
matter as is in this bill
um that there were several people that
served on that committee and are still
serving on that committee that would be
very beneficial their recollection of
this subject matter would be very useful
to a subcommittee of our committee uh
that use works on the retainment of this
bill and I spoke with uh chairman Lynn
prior to us convening this morning and I
I think it might be worth it to as he
said they would be willing to work with
us we we appoint a subcommittee and ask
the speaker or or the chairman of
Judiciary also to assign some members of
his committee to work with us so that we
uh actually have subject matter experts
working on this so we don't have to all
be schooled in civil law
um all I heard is I volunteered a chair
subcommittee is that is that was that
what everyone else heard I think yeah I
think so yeah okay with that I'm going
to ask the clerk to call the roll on
retention
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative Lynn yes
representative who yes representative
janfrin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative gathrate yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
chairman chairman motion is unanimous
20-0 and House Bill 593 is retained
standby for information forthcoming in
the next week on subcommittees and
things like that and I closed the
executive session and stand by before we
break
foreign
this point I'm going to open an
executive session on a bill that we had
already opened and
um
or was I don't I don't know coffee
opened or not but it was scheduled
um it's House Bill 653
I'm an open executive session
um I have discussed it with the
representative gathright who agrees
to open the executive session on this
now
and I'm going to recognize myself for a
motion to retain
seconded by representative gathright
I'll speak to my motion this is another
bail bill
um we've discussed what we're going to
work on this bill issue over the summer
we already have a study committee or
commission formed out of one of the
bills and it's my intention to take
pieces from all the bills and work with
them and there's also another bill that
is almost identical coming out of the
Senate so I think that with all these
bail bills flying around in the orbit we
need to collect them and clean them up
and um and take a serious look at it as
well as some of you are aware I'm
working on a technology issue that's
going to assist with this as well with
the state police so with that I'm going
to open it up for further discussion
the very beginning we realized what we
had
from the very beginning we realized that
we have quite a few bail bills and we do
want to do due diligence with the right
thing to do and the correct process for
everything so I agree 100 with our chair
uh thank you again
I just want to be clear to the sponsors
to the people here to the public we take
this bail issue very seriously and we
are going to work on it and we will
produce a piece of legislation this year
um but we want to we want to be measured
cautious and ensure that everything's
covered while at the same time making
sure that we're not violating anyone's
rights so I want all the stakeholders to
agree on whatever piece of legislation
comes out
um
so with that I'll ask the clerk to call
to roll on the motion to retain House
Bill 653
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt
yes representative Lynn yes
representative Prue yes
yes representative janvin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yeah representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
guthright yes representative Muse
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes no representative Newell uh yes
representative Brennan yes
representative wheeler
no
chairman Roy
cheer votes yes motion passes 18-2
is there an objection to consent
representative wheeler or representative
Murray is retained oh yeah never mind
I don't care then
uh with that the bill is retained in our
business for the day is concluded thank
you for attending and all of your input
and send pay attention your emails
they'll be we're all off next week
um
we are having our tour of the Department
of Corrections on Wednesday so if you
are interested it is a voluntary thing I
know some of you have said you can't
make it and that's regrettable but that
I got to do it that day so um look for
email from me today that explains what
time and where to meet and we will take
our tour of the male and female
facilities and
go ahead thank you for making exact two
hours that's all oh hey do the business
get out of here